over a thousand republic service
employees could strike here in las vegas
in the coming weeks this comes as
contract negotiations continue between
the company and the workers union if
they don't come to an agreement could
cause some problems across southern
nevada sasha loftis joining us live
tonight with more on what this might
mean for you
denise and brian it's something we all
take for granted you get your trash you
throw it into a dumpster like this and
it's hauled away but if this strike
happens it could leave garbage to pile
up in places like this
trash we all have it and pay to get it
hauled away
but an announcement made this week could
throw a wrench in the process that would
for sure be an inconvenience on tuesday
around 1200 republic services employees
voted to authorize a strike as contract
negotiations between the company and
teamster local 631 intensify
if an agreement isn't reached by may
31st
garbage pickup could stop at casinos
businesses and homes across the valley
which has customers like john vance
concerned i could pile up really
terrible not everybody can load it up
and go down to the transfer station
republic services released a statement
calling this a quote formality to put
pressure on them and said the threat of
a strike put stress on all hard-working
employees the company also said it would
extend its current contract to complete
negotiations it's got something that
will have to be definitely handled these
union members say they've had enough and
need to make it clear they deserve
better but vance says he hopes they take
the time to think about what this kind
of move could mean
for everyone i was in the union for
several years and there's better ways of
settling it than striking
i did reach out to teamsters 6 31 for an
interview or statement they said they
cannot speak on this as they are still
in the middle of negotiations now as for
that statement from republic services we
have the entire thing on our website
eight newsnow dot com reporting live
tonight sasha loftis live local now